good morning good afternoon good evening
everyone welcome back to GameSpot it is
the second day on our game of the year
countdown which means we will be
announcing our number 9 game of 2017
yesterday we showed off near automata
that was our number 10 game I got that
coveted last spot on our list I'm Mike
my Hardy here with Peter Brown hello
Kelly claggy hello and Jimmy thang
hello and we are momentarily going to
show you our number 9 game as voted on
by the games by staff but first I want
to reiterate our schedule every weekday
from now until December 20th which is
next Wednesday at 10 a.m. Pacific every
day we are going to be announcing a game
and then on Wednesday the 20th we will
be announcing our top three games in a
mega stream but without further ado here
is our number 9 game I'm just gonna
start at the beginning with the house I
[Music]
thought it was time I heard the stories
for myself and found out what happened
to everyone else
maybe we believed so much in a family
curse
we made it real
dear diary I'll be gone soon but I
wanted to tell somebody about what's
gonna happen
[Music]
turns out my mom was really good at
keeping secrets
[Music]
they think we've been surrounded by
death for so long we've just gotten used
to it
[Music]
so there you have it what remains of
Edith Finch from Giants Pharaoh is
GameSpot's
number nine game of the year as voted on
by GameSpot staff callyblackie and Jimmy
thank you both played that well I mean
we all played it but you both like were
heavily arguing for it in our game of
the year which encouraged me to go try
it out finally and I really liked it I
mean Jimmy you said obviously like the
genre the sub-genre has come to mean I
was walking simulators used to be kind
of derogatory but now it's been embraced
by people who make those games but you
were saying that kind of lured you in
but then the game became something
different the more you play that you
want to talk about that yeah sure so it
is it is a walking simulator but you
know as someone who's played you know
decent amount of walking simulators it's
you know easily my favorite one and just
like watching that that footage just
gave me kind of chills like oh man the
games so cool and you play as Edith
Finch and you explore your old family's
estate and there may or may not be a
family curse they end up killing all
your relatives and as you explore the
larger-than-life mansion and explore the
the rooms of your old relatives
you get to sort of flashback and see the
last moments of their lives yeah and it
kind of takes place over this frame
story and like you said you're exploring
this house but then they're also these
little vignettes as you're looking back
on those family members who in one way
or another kind of died unexpectedly or
tragically or most of them at least and
you're kind of trying to figure out
where you fit into all this as the
current day Edith Finch and then Kelly
you were saying like also there's like a
magical realism quality to the story you
want talk about like the surreal aspects
that kind of unfold throughout the game
absolutely so the first vignette that
you actually do is probably the most
surreal you kind of embody your
long-lost relative who died very young
so she's a little girl that you're
playing and she goes to bed without
dinner and ends up occupying the body of
a cat in an owl in a shark and you you
follow her like dreamlike Jordan journey
through those animals and that's kind of
how the game opens in a lot of ways is
when it really opens up and it's still
grounded in reality but it's I think the
surrealism helps enhance the is there
is there not a curse aspect of the game
part of that was when she took the tube
of toothpaste down the hole but yeah
like that's the actual way that the
gameplay in these vignettes kind of
breaks the the borders of the walking
simulator genre right like you go into
there's there's a famous one later on
where you're controlling something
differently on both so there's the two
there's the one later on that like it's
one of the moments of the year that
people are talking about its kind of
level it's the cannery level right
you're controlling you're someone at a
cannery literally just like with one
analog stick you're controlling one hand
cutting off fish heads to like put them
into the pile and then of course your
imagination starts running wild and with
the other analog stick you are
controlling your imagination and I don't
want to spoil where it goes we are going
to be playing this game if you're
watching this live we're gonna be
playing it live momentarily after this
discussion but right now we won't spoil
it because there is there are some great
moments in this vignette but I think
this game is super special Jimmy because
it can actually tie what you're doing
into the feeling of the characters I
think this is really indicative of that
right like he is still sort of focusing
on his job but his mind is also
wandering you can see right here on this
actual MIDI game which he's imagining
he's kind of creating this Kingdom in
his imagination did you find that the
vignettes like kind of elsewhere also
tied to these characters and unique ways
yeah when regards to that specific the
fish factory one you know it deals with
certain mature themes like depression
and drug addiction and things like that
without giving too much away and you
know when you're playing that sequence
using the both analog sticks to like
play out your fantasy and then also do
your mundane job you know it leads to
somewhere ultimately leads to his demise
as we kind of stated and it's like a
very powerful storytelling tool that can
only be told through the medium of video
games which I find very powerful and
just going back to the UM that little
girl look at the toothpaste thing like I
have like a younger sister who I liked
helped raise and she's like 10 years
younger than me and things like that and
the game so well voice acted that you
know you hear this little girl's voice
and you feel very sympathetic and I
think we've I think most of us have lost
somebody
we deeply care about and things like
that it's very touching in that and that
aspect yeah Kelly did you like these
characters any of them stand out from
your time playing game even though you
don't even really meet most of them if
not all of them yeah I mean like pretty
much everybody in the game is long dead
which i think is it's interesting that
you get so drawn into those characters I
really really like Barbara who was a
child star
I think her van yeah it's really
interesting and we'll check that out
later with her I think you kind of get
this sense of like she peaked so young
that she doesn't know where to go
and they tell that so effectively even
in the the layout of her room right so
it's not just the vignettes that tell
these stories and draw you into these
characters it's also the level design
and the general layout of the house
especially when you walk through it as
Edith and then you go through it again
as one of her family members so you see
Barbara's room and it's full of her
childhood stuff you don't really see the
evidence of a teenager too much in that
room and so for her for me that was a
really standout character and also
there's one with a baby that's really
heartbreaking yeah you get drawn in both
to the the baby and the parents in that
in that vignette and and of course the
cannery level is is my favorite of the
whole game yeah developer giant Sparrow
I believe it was 2012 they also did the
unfinished Swan when you're painting the
white environments black to kind of
navigate it but totally I feel like
their games always kind of nail this
like sombre almost mysterious tone do
you find that that's the case here we
even finish oh absolutely I mean the
house before you get to it you know
you're basically are saying like yeah
like my mom's healed everything up like
she doesn't want anyone going anywhere
and you are going through these secret
passageways and you are finding things
that are deceptive like when you first
see them then you start to investigate
and you sort of uncover the real mystery
behind them all and it's it's very
revealing in a way and it's very
surprising as well it like the walking
simulator part of this game like you
don't literally do a lot of walking but
you do a lot of environmental
exploration in ways that I wasn't used
to so that was really interesting to see
this is your cool house it reminds me of
like this is weird but Spencer mansion
from Resident Evil there's like a
justification why like yeah
there are booby traps well that's
there's no booby traps in this game
that's Resident Evil but
there are like secret passageways and
they kind of described why like the
matriarch was kind of that senile but
paranoid in the way and then of course
the moms sealed up a lot of this stuff
so there are like and then you know like
the eccentric like architects that built
the house when they came over from
Norway was it summer Scandinavian some
yeah I think I mean it for a real life
comparison it reminds me a lot of the
Winchester Mystery House if you've ever
been there it's you know the the wife of
the you know when like Winchester rifle
air basically who continued building the
house because she was haunted with guilt
from all the people who were killed by
Winchester rifles yeah and she was
basically like a little you know
unhinged and she kept building until the
very day she died so if you go to that
house there's like stairways to nowhere
and like weird little doorways and so
this house reminds me a lot of that yeah
Falls yeah it's like a doorway that
opens into yeah into a pitfall or a door
that opens up to another door like it's
it reminded me a lot of that except this
house the layout of face much more sense
because you're designed to go through it
yeah in in a few ways what remains of
Edith Finch actually kind of scratched a
niche that gone home did not and I
mentioned gone home it wasn't the first
walking simulator game but it was kind
of the one that sparked the huge
conversation around it and almost like
created the sub-genre I'd say like after
dear Esther and me it's like that but in
gone home I was kind of and I think a
lot of people were expecting it to be
like a haunted house or they're
expecting there to be some sort of
surrealistic thing happening or it's
like like supernatural yeah that game
played off of the horror expectations
really well I thought for sure and this
one actually just like went a step
further and gave you that but then
played with those like it was it would
have been enough to give you all these
secret passageways and these characters
and these weird because a lot of
characters are eccentric the whole
family is kind of because of the curse
that they perceive especially when you
go to the cemetery next to the house who
I believe it was Edie the matriarch who
designed the cemetery I could be wrong
and you can see each of the the
tombstones has a representation of that
person stuff it's a very and like the
way it snakes around the house it's like
haphazardly built because people keep
dying and you can tell that paranoia has
really taken hold it's this is another
weird comparison it reminds me like the
Royal Tenenbaums a house like it's so
characteristic of each person like as
you walk through the ground you get a
sense of Barbara because of her room
like you can like heli you said like she
peaked early but all of the memorabilia
in her in her room is still from when
she was like eight as a child star and
then you go to Louis's room and you can
see like weed posters and like
legalizing marijuana this is and set in
Washington Pacific Northwest but it's
just so great at characterizing these
people despite the fact that you never
meet them and it's tough to do but
walking simulators have done that like I
remember everybody's gone to the rapture
from a couple years ago also did that
really well but Jimmy did you find that
the setting has stuck with you over the
months since you played the game yeah I
mean it's I think I mentioned it's sort
of larger than life it helps that the
graphics are actually really amazing and
Kelly and I were just playing before the
stream and the environments are so
detailed and there's like bookshelves
that if you look straight up at the
ceiling there's like a bookshelf up
there and like normally you wouldn't you
know who looks up at the ceiling kind of
thing but in a lot of ways the house
sort of the architecture house defies
like physics you know as you explore
upwards the house is very vertical and
it's the explore like the roofs and and
above there's like a boat up there for
some reason there's our boat on top of
your house and then there's like rooms
both off of that and it's sort of
mystical magical and it's a very cool
world to explore yeah it's almost like
what I wanted my house to be when I was
eight yeah but and then they just kind
of gave me that but I don't know Kelly
in general like when you're looking back
at what remains of youth Finch obviously
it's stuck with a lot of us because a
lot of people wanted to send our top ten
list and elsewhere other people are
mentioning in game of the Year awards
and everything what was it that really
stuck with you about this game like in
general that you can't really stop
thinking about over the months I really
can't stop thinking about the the
environmental storytelling I think it's
so well done and we talked about you
know previous walking Sims and and how
they achieve that and I think like I was
talking about with Barbara I think I
really have a sense for how the house is
laid out even though it makes no sense
if that if that makes sense
it so that's really stuck with me and I
think the way that that brought me into
the family's grief and made me think
about death in a way that I never have
before is the thing I'm still thinking
about yeah okay so what remains of Edith
Finch is our number nine game of the
year again yesterday we announced Nier
automata was our number 10
and then giant sparrows what remains of
Edith Finch which released earlier in
the year which already has a lot of
great releases that is our number 9 we
are going to play it momentarily if
you're watching this on youtube or
GameSpot after the fact go check out the
rest of our game of your coverage we
have discussions and we'll have live
streams on every game but now let's get
to playing what remains of youth Finch I
will give them like a spoiler warning
because we are we're playing how I can
half-hour into the game yeah roughly I'm
talking about half hour into the game
and this is the segment if you have not
played the game it could take you like
two to three hours depending on how much
time it's been exploring each room I
think it took me like two and you guys
are saying something similar a little
more than two and a half maybe yeah so
we might spoil some stuff if you're
watching this and we can talk about
stuff later on so you haven't played it
go played it otherwise please stick
around and hang out and watch us play
gameplay wise not the most exciting game
to watch but obviously like us watching
it's johnny memories from when we played
it and everything so it's just like like
you guys set the incredibly detailed
game it's like gorgeous to look at
yeah before we started when Jimmy and I
were just running through it we're
noticing things in this room like Jimmy
go up to that like birthday cake like
Barbara died in 1960 and there's this
cake in this room and it's freaking
disgusting but like I didn't notice that
the first time I was going through
because there was just so much to take
in so we were noticing things there's so
much in this room spilled things records
newspapers it's really impressive the
amount of detail well yeah that's
nothing like you just mentioned it to
you cheap 3d glasses you see things I
mean obviously we have those now but
those like the old-school ones you have
things from the air above like when they
died or before at least things that were
big at the time like the typewriter you
saw is pretty old on her desk
yeah even the cat clock I really liked
when we were looking at the time it's
like 3:00 a.m. yeah what's the character
who hold him up himself up under the
house thirty years I forget his name
yeah the Hong Kong yeah and like because
I remember like there there are legends
about the family like from the nearby
towns and they were saying like a mole
man emerged from the house one day yeah
yeah and then you find out later on it
like oh [ __ ] that was her uncle i freed
his name well problem he might actually
get to that it's like that was her uncle
and he
like that was when I realized the game
was almost like a dark comedy yeah when
he emerged from the he finally got the
courage to leave and then a train hit
and it was immediately two minutes later
yeah oh my god there's pretty rough yeah
and this one I left then I think like I
felt bad but it it's almost like a dark
haunting that what absolutely is there's
there's elements of comedy in this and
this vignette in particular actually has
some comedic elements and I think it's
in a different style than the rest of
them which we will see should I help
into it yeah yeah let's do it so this is
one of the vignettes so this is like the
frame story the house exploring the
house as present-day Edith Finch yeah so
I'm surprised Edie saved this one if I
could get somebody like what's the
what's the classic Tales from the Crypt
Paul pours it season that wasn't self in
the Crypt told by a character kind of
like this yeah yeah yeah I really like
this get some audio we got a little bit
yeah you can turn off the TVs in the
studio film it just don't have the
remote just to know when to perceive
yeah yeah we turn it up go off the text
I also love the mailbox when you're
first approached the house the beginning
it's actually like a replica of the
house oh yeah I just think the comic
book style for this especially because
it was 1960 is so cool yeah for sure
it's funny to watch the game to watch
this by itself you might think the rest
of the game is like this but everybody
is so different like in terms of the
presentations you know how you play it
this is just literally an interactive
novel yeah if you can call it
interactive yeah someone get way more
involved I think it's interesting how
like this one is told from an outsider's
perspective and a lot of them are kind
of it merges with the actual family
members truth with the
outside impression of what happened yeah
this one especially so is like somebody
else interpreting what happened to her
right in the same way that like Oh a
mole man emerge from under yeah but then
you're like oh my and I I think the the
cool thing about that is is being able
to kind of have this more
multi-dimensional view of the characters
yeah I look what's this character's name
of the sport jacket her boyfriend her
who just like no matter how bad things
go he's just acting like it's a
performance like I'm not sensing actual
terror and then this is how you figure
out how to get in the basement in
present day yeah that becomes kind of
weird you're like how did Outsiders know
about that but maybe like that was part
of I know a police report yeah not that
this game is going for realism but well
it isn't it isn't yeah Oh Rick is his
name I kind of wanted his name to be
Chad he's like the Steve he is totally a
Steve yeah did you guys interact or that
music box before this cuz I did I did
spin it long enough and I don't even
know if they let you I don't know if
they do either because she tells this
thing about like oh my grandpa made this
for Barbra grandpa Odin cuz if you spin
it a little bit the musical start so why
would you keep spinning yeah that's
worth noting too that before you went I
wasn't actually playing but now it's
sort of giving control to yeah the music
is so good yeah awesome
you're sweet the shooter thirteen back
in like 2007 dissociative yeah like
graphic novel style it was it was
different a lot yeah that wasn't a great
game knows it was different I really
that was the first game I played it
looked like this was the first game i
ever played 13 roman numerals did you
play that Kelly no okay you actually
probably liked it back in the day I want
to shoot yeah I love that total Bowl the
left just super like not creepy but like
oh it's creepy yeah I liked is that it's
a hook man killer is he riding a swing
wait look at the other one who's the
other one's supposed to be barber Molly
Molly
my god so these are all other characters
that we did not notice these things so
though and then that wasn't kid dies on
a swing that's this and yeah and Molly
turned into an owl that's the one we
talked about earlier that's I didn't
even notice that that's crazy
so Molly no wait that's what he gets
but he was just presumably doing that to
try to get her actually scared for the
performance believes like method acting
when I said I liked him I don't actually
like another person I just think he's
funny
barbar if you see my other grudge and
she was just left with the crutch next
to her I still can finish this section
so I don't know what happens the length
of this game is so perfect like I feel
like it did not wear out its Warface
yeah
similar length is like gone home DRS
dear Esther was really short Oh Walter
is the one the uncle who hmm right yeah
that sounds familiar
there's that library that's always
sealed up and present there they had to
listen to the song today must've so just
an Hubbard is like yeah whatever okay I
like to unfinished Vaughn a lot of slide
that was John Carter he actually yeah we
actually interview was but there's some
yeah yeah so here's round they're
confused maybe not ways that's what
they're going for but was it actually an
escaped convict that came is that part
of the necklace like I think this is
part of the mythos and what actually
happened to her like so what she died
because a gang of people actually did
come to house yeah okay I didn't know if
how much this was fabricated I guess
that's the fun part though yeah what's
real and what's not and that's like kind
of what Edith is doing when she visits
the house anyway yeah would you do me a
favor yeah you crowd can you crouch in
this game or now no they probably can't
let you right here okay nevermind sorry
what were you saying
Kelly oh so this is Halloween night I
think and if I remember correctly when I
looked at her tombstone later she was
also born on Halloween okay but I don't
quote me on that I remember thinking
that was weird so this is really cool in
terms of level design too because the
graphic novels showed you how to open
the door in the basement but he would
not have known to crawl through there
right away unless you had already gone
through there in this present day so
it's like you're kind of tying them both
together
it's super cool it's really smart this
is Molly's real Oliver yeah and the
doors haven't been sealed yet so you can
go out the door yeah
oh you are totally right Walter because
if this goes into the mm-hmm you wanna
call it shelter
yeah bunker yeah I mean yes yes and then
he's just traumatized in the present day
you can see this part of the Bannister
has been repaired mm-hmm it's just so
cool like I went and checked it after
this vignette yeah it's funny that's
another thing not to keep comparing it
to gone home but like gone home showed
you the current state of things and then
you kind of have to infer what happened
in the past this also toys with that
like this happened but also maybe
something happened between these two
states that actually kind of led to this
how'd also who's loved to live in this
house right
well without the curse yeah like the way
she describes it at first as like it's
like I had a sinister vile like a smile
too many teeth yes the writing this is
great yeah I hope I did not really like
penis at first the character you play as
she just felt like they were going too
hard into the Millennial thing mm-hmm
but as that goes on I actually start to
like her a lot
surprise
and she saw what kind of monsters they
were and she realized what was about to
happen
yeah like thinking about what actually
has is super creepy mm-hmm which is that
this is the brain ultra no it looks like
Mars Attacks right yeah that was it I
guess the police blame like you don't
that's why if you could crouch those
from Walter was on the bed but I guess
they purposely
real detail saying cuz you don't do the
swing vignette until later mm-hmm
I did it before this oh really yeah okay
I think you did this like wasting water
nurses but a weird habit of doing that
now I know I just think it was her
boyfriend the second time around victory
yeah oh yeah it's cool it's like you go
through the family tree and you can see
oh see yeah you did this okay yeah
that's interesting maybe Rick was just
like a shitty dude and maybe he X maybe
he was trying to get the performance out
of her or in the story of enemies over
and actually scared her too much and
hurt her but and or maybe he was just or
maybe he was yeah yeah blatant scream I
liked what what Edith says is like for
Edie the who was Barbara's music um for
Edie that was a happy ending that comic
because she became famous yeah I think
back there was the quickest win yeah I
think you want to go that way tear that
music box and also you can check the
banister which is crazy oh yeah oh yeah
I did ya know something yeah whenever
people ask me about my family the first
thing they always want to know about is
Barbara no it's downstairs
yeah but yeah that but see the banister
there you can see where yeah that's cool
I didn't notice how the first day yeah
you can see where somebody fell through
it they'll just slap shot kind of thing
put together yeah okay it's around the
corner let's turn around I should get
downstairs
so dark right there
this TV is dark sometime in our studio
yes like I think I turned it till the
music started then I stopped it's the
same so I'm not sure if you can well
she I think she starts talking right
after that Oh gotcha so it kind of
interrupts anyway so yeah I'd say
there's a little less than halfway
through the game maybe depending on how
long you taking yeah depending on what
order you do them into it didn't even
occur to me that you can actually play
it in different sequence yeah the
spaceman is also like you're really
similar to mine back in the day I had a
pool table right next to the laundry
really yeah mom said the basement was
off-limits
unless I wanted another tetanus shot oh
sure you know what also the hey you can
see like these smaller models of the
Dragons slide he was building outside
that eventually bred them but B I'm
pretty sure those totem things that we
saw are outside now so he was just
building those in like memoriam for them
I guess he must be pretty sure I saw the
owl one outside before without making a
scene down to the basement ones carrying
packages
it is turn yep this way turn right at it
I'm going I got the fridge she was
hiding present Rick's still in there
just skeleton it turned out she was
go forward yeah go for it I remember
asking mom once about where Walter he'd
gone she said after Barbara died he got
his far away as he could if there's a
pattern all these stories I think it's
that none of us has gotten very far I
really do like how the character is like
the mom of the characters like really
didn't want them to know all these
stories I guess she thought the curse
was like making their lives worse
knowing about it okay whereas you be the
great grandma her grandma thought that
it was like worthwhile they know their
stories well I can't believe I've been
down here for 30 years
on that first day after the shaking
started I didn't survive
[Music]
but after these babies are talking now
he's sitting on my hand that's what kept
me sane
[Applause]
having a schedule moving for today I
always expect it to be dead tomorrow
it's have one issue with this I think
calendar Edie's been going downstairs
all time oh they just said that right
she knows that he's Moody he's been
taking care of him but mom eat it's mom
hit it gotcha okay but Edie's hurt
didn't everybody know he lived down here
at the time it seems or no azita so like
he used to see ET going down there
didn't know what yeah and yeah so that
was one thing I was like so he's been
surviving down here without anybody else
in calendars no big owners so Edie is
his mom yeah and she's been coming was
you could just see his liver spot now
maybe because what does that mean you're
talking about
earthquake yeah well yeah and I think
that's the train going by isn't it - yes
it's look like a raw egg yolks it's been
three years yeah and he hasn't there
hasn't been shaking which we know is a
train they also did mind they did
mention minor earthquakes as well right
yes I mean Northwest is like were than
you read that a feature that pull it up
grip it there's a couple years ago them
feature with a prize Pulitzer Prize
winner for feature writing was a called
the really big one it was about how like
oh yeah if the earthquake the possible
earthquake happens in the northwest it
would be the worst natural disaster like
in the world ever okay but doesn't
haven't yet but to Walter who's been
down here since he was a child he thinks
it's like the curse coming after him
yeah there's no understanding of certain
things that
would become commonplace for most people
check out this bunker this is someone
who definitely thinks that the world is
gonna end
yeah maybe this is all a mistake
but I need to start living the same day
even if it kills me much more sinister
taking on groundhogs that this looks a
lot like that you think oh yeah yeah it
was 2015 I believe I'm gonna appreciate
14th sorry another walking simulator
yeah I don't mind if I were having
month for a seat
[Music]
you can already imagine this the whole
time they lead up to that really well
like he's on the rail which actually no
[ __ ] away and plus if you look at the
2005 there beforehand me like oh you
know he's gonna die soon yeah he must've
been fifty something I guess Waldo so
her mom didn't know he was down there
okay yeah so Sam is so Walter is like
her great-uncle yeah
Edie's her great-grandma it took me a
while to understand I'm really bad at
that easy yeah the one who's like Edie's
the one who has been yeah maintaining
the family story the whole time and like
Sam is eat eat eat it's moms dads or her
grandpa both the other thing yeah
it took me a really long time I figured
I really benefit Jimmy you want to do
maybe get to the next vignette maybe I
think the next one if I'm correct is
shorter we could do that and then call
it a livestream yeah that was good also
I love the books lining this I know I
mean stories in general are a huge kind
of motif in this game but it seems like
everybody in the family was a avid
reader mm-hmm I can only imagine I don't
want to make this is still dumpster
mm-hmm
now that there's only one of the slack
work maybe two
I thought it was time I heard the
stories for myself
and found out what happened to everyone
else
but now I'm all read the stories
themselves might be the problem
maybe we believed so much as a family
curse
we made it real
yeah there's even a toy train oh my god
they're on the nose those finches yeah
Edie got nothing back
that's the original house that spend
right over from Norway yeah so he
brought you find out through a story
that he brought their original house
like overseas yeah but then it was
shipwrecked and so the original house
that she lived in is out there that red
light how would you get from Norway to
Washington is there a waterway or not
thinking about it there must be right
like some sort of you know through the
Arctic I mean you got to do a real
arduous leg so I mean any trip is harder
than you have a house on top yeah why
not go to like you know I didn't even
think about that see right here look at
your left no stop right there
left right there that's her oh wow
that's where I know oh my god and the
swing right under there's Molly where's
the swings right like literally at the
bottom of her yeah oh my god that's
pretty cool that's so haunting look how
beautiful this game looks yeah the
graphics don't get much better to be
honest I feel as lost as you probably do
right now
there's another thing about the length
of the game it's easy to replay without
feeling like you're just investing in
another track and I feel like I keep
learning new things yeah like I I didn't
know I'd pick up on that I didn't
realize like I'd have a new theory about
what happened to Barbara yeah I also
didn't realize that the toothpaste was
probably what killed Molly she and
berries off the yeah Russell toe right
here's mrs. Joe was like poisonous berry
and the care that was massacred yeah the
food yeah I forgot about that too
because I at that point I didn't really
understand what the game was doing same
so I was like why is is this just like
her why is she going on a trip yeah you
know otherwise the bathtub is pretty
sinister the bathtub is really sinister
I forget what child that was it was one
of the ones it was
Edith's mom's brother baby brother yeah
because he does yeah eatest mom's
parents were fighting and then they kind
of blamed each other yeah
so actually let's look at the cemetery
and we can colleagues I do want to show
this or is that your keep going yet
the Pet Sematary may be more
uncomfortable than me
three of the gerbils are mine I had a
hard time not getting her gerbils I had
a hard time locating which gerbils were
hers cuz a lot of them had died in the
90s and she was like born in 97 or
something yeah you can see Bubber Finch
the star there yeah Walter's just done
tiny little dude in a tunnel yep yep
council was the one on us where's Molly
with the cat oh yeah cuz they named the
cat after Molly or after Molly like it
was a name sacred it she just liked the
name Molly or something I forget
everybody else thought I was weird but
eating named the cat Molly I think yeah
I'm sure it had been Edie's idea my mama
was always trying to move on but really
the past never went away
at first I really didn't like the text
on screen yeah but I liked it more and
more that's been and yeah
[Music]
let's check the house out and then
and this thing mm-hmm mm not entendre
there's a punch with you last you go
there later on during low tide with a
yeah one night it's creating how much I
remember of this despite the fact that I
play it once and it's like two hours
long yeah it alrighty well that showed a
good chunk of it like I said there's one
later on that like people never stop
talking about with the cannery kind of
messes with how you're playing with the
game how you're interacting with the
character but yeah that is what remains
of Edith Finch thanks for sticking
around if you stuck around to watch it
live on YouTube or GameSpot again we're
gonna be doing Game of the Year
announcements every weekday until
December 20th next Wednesday when we
announce our top three games I almost
just said what one of them was don't do
it yeah anyway thanks for sticking
around if you haven't played what it
means to be a Finch and you didn't mind
if we spoiled some stuff go play it'll
take you like two hours maybe even less
if you feel like getting through it
quickly although I don't advise that but
again we'll be back tomorrow at 10:00
a.m. Pacific to announce our number 8
game today was what remains of Heath
Finch yesterday our number 10 game was
near automata so try to play both of
those when you get some time off coming
up on the holidays but until tomorrow
we'll see you then have a good day
you